Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, and this is the first video in the series of understanding
your DNA and newer series that I just put in together, and we're going to speak about
your SNP report, your single nucleotide polymorphism genetic report that you're receiving.
So this is really for those people that did a 23andMe or that are thinking about doing
a 23andMe genetic test, and are having us analyze that test, putting it through our
software and giving you some recommendations from a nutritional, nutraceutical and possibly
dietary perspective on the next steps to take.
So the initial part of your genetics that we look at is your gut health.
There's much to be said on our website, gut health, because the health of your intestinal
tract really is a telltale side for the health of your entire body, even if you say, well,
I'm not having any gut problems, I have a normal bowel movement and I never have any tummy
aches that I could digest anything, and I got a stomach like a, like a, like a, that could
break down anything and have no issues, really you could have a whole bunch of inflammation
going on, you could have a bunch of problems with leaky gut issues, not even know it, not
have any gut symptoms whatsoever.
You've heard me say before that the health of your gut equals the health of your brain
and the health of the rest of the body, any inflammation of the gut equals inflammation of
the brain and inflammation of the rest of the body, and right now we want to take a look
at the genetics of that, and how that plays a part.
So that's what we're going to discuss right now.
So I trust that you've done your 23andMe and maybe after this presentation, if you haven't,
you may choose to do your 23andMe, again, that is a genetic profile, and from 23andMe you
will get a bunch of fun little data back, like I'm 12% dramatic and 7% French and things, but
I don't really care about that.
We want to look at your raw data, put it into our software and really see what's going
on from a genetic perspective.
Your diet is so important, what goes on in your intestinal tract is so important and literally
on a weekly basis, they're coming up with new studies speaking about the importance of
the health of your microbiota.
That is really, really important.
Now, genetics is not the only way that we look at that, so understand we don't solely look
at your genetics to understand your gut health, and I'll speak a little bit about that
as we go look.
But your immune system, you talk about somebody with cancer or somebody with Lyme disease,
your immune system is made up primarily, having to do with your microbiota and the gut.
So the health of that is so important when you're dealing with more chronic conditions.
So variants that impact gut health and digestion is what we're going to talk about.
So this is important when we look at your genetics, so let's dive into this.
The first genes that you're going to see on my report that you'll receive is your HLA
genes.
Now, I do have to give you a little bit of data though.
We are updating this genetic report literally on a weekly basis.
So I cannot keep up, but some of my slides you may say, well, my report looks a little
bit different.
That's because it's updated from the time that I did this presentation.
So just bear with me and there may be more data on your report.
So the purpose of me doing this presentation is for you to look at your report and understand
based upon what the genetic defects and variants that you have versus what I'm explaining, what
they mean here.
So you're going to have to do your homework.
You're not going to have me one-on-one explaining each one of these genes to you.
It's just not humanly possible for me to do that.
That's why I created these videos.
So when you look at your reports, page one or two or three, depending on what your report
looks like, the first genes that you're going to see most likely are these HLA genes.
Now, these HLA genes are for gluten sensitivity, these MCM-6 genes are for lactose ability to
digest a dairy, a lactose that's the sugar in dairy.
So a person with this genetic profile, as you see on this slide, they have a two on this
bottom HLA gene, which means they have a double olio defect of that gene, can't get any worse
of that.
They have a one in that third one down of the HLA genes.
Does this mean that they're gluten sensitive?
Does this mean that they should stay off gluten?
The answer is no, it doesn't.
You don't, at least in my book, we don't make the decision whether the person should be gluten-free
or dairy-free based upon their genes.
Now it does give us some clues.
If a person has any HLA genes here, any defects, so if there's, if all of these are blank
after each one of these genes, then the chance that they will have celiac is less.
The chance that they will have full-blown celiac disease or a high sensitivity to gluten is
less, but it does not mean that it's not going to be there.
So we want to look at other tests for that.
The MCM-6 gene right here talks about your ability to digest lactose.
When you have a two there, like this person does, they actually could digest lactose better.
It may have said that incorrectly on another slide, presentations, or I apologize.
But this person has the ability to digest lactose better.
But understand, I wouldn't make the decision that the person should be dairy-free or gluten-free
based upon this genetic picture because for instance, this MCM-6 gene has to do with
lactose.
People that have dairy sensitivities, it really isn't due to the lactose.
It's due to the k-seed in the dairy.
So what you want to do is test for k-seed issues, whether the person has antibody to the peptides,
that is the particles of the k-seed protein.
If they have antibodies in their blood or they're got to those k-seed peptides, the same thing
with gluten, do they have antibodies to the gliaden?
That's the protein and gluten to the gliaden peptides.
That's the particles of that protein.
So it gets much more complicated than simply genetics when you're talking about inflammatory
food things going out of the gut.
So don't make the decision whether you should be gluten-free based upon your genes or whether
you should be dairy-free based upon your genes.
So I make that very clear.
This only tells you whether you have a greater risk of having celiac or gluten intolerance.
It doesn't tell you if you do.
So the other test that I would run out of patients in our office is a test from a CyRECS lab.
So if you have a local doctor that you work with a functional medicine doctor, that would
be the most accurate test currently, the time of this taping, to test for food intolerances.
And it intolerance has to do with your immune system, your genetics, per se.
So it's an immune function.
You've created antibodies to particles of food, typically protein particles, which are called
peptides.
You've created antibodies against those which you shouldn't have.
And it's typically typically because a person has leaky gut.
Leaky gut is where you have damaged gut cells, typically due to other inflammatory processes
going out of the gut, like eating genetically-modified foods, consuming a lot of toxins, et cetera.
That damages the gut cells.
The opening between the cells is larger than it should have been.
Particles of food, typically peptides, that should never have gotten across the gut border,
are going across the gut border, and your immune system in the blood is going, what in the
neck is that thing?
Let's kill it.
So it tries to kill it, and of course it's not a living organism, and your body, then your
immune system, your B cells, make antibodies against that thing.
And now you have circulated antibodies against food particles.
And so now every time you eat that food particle, you have this ramped up inflammation because
your immune system is trying to kill it.
So that is not a good thing, and that causes more damage in the gut, because you got this
constant ramped up inflammation in the gut.
And remember, inflammation in the gut equals inflammation in the body.
So we have to look at food as a causative piece of every disease.
You have to.
You have to look at diet as a cause of the piece of every disease.
For someone to say that your cancer, oh, that's not caused by diet, you're crazy.
They're crazy.
There's so much information out there that speaks to that.
Now is food the cause of a cancer?
I doubt it.
But is food causing more inflammation that can cause ill health in the body?
Absolutely.
So diet has to do with everything.
So if you're not willing to make dietary changes and dietary restrictions, and you're just
going to do your DNA and you're just going to take my advice as far as what's based upon
your steps, your genetic defects here, you're going to miss a big piece of getting healthy.
So don't expect that you're just going to address your genes and you're going to get healthy.
The purpose of this whole presentation and the purpose of being into genetics is that it
can be a missing link for other things, but you cannot take one piece and ignore the others.
So diet is extremely important.
Now we're doing this test on you, this test that's shown on the screen right here.
We're going over your genetics, but I how do you know this point because diet is so important?
And if you have ill health and you've never investigated whether you have inflammatory
processes going on and you're going to go on in your body that is caused from antibodies
that your immune system is made to different food particles, and you're continuing to eat
those food particles, you're just going to be beaten your head against the wall to try to
get better.
So I'd highly recommend that you find a functional medicine doctor that could do these CyRex tests.
If you don't, we do these on our full patient, so you can call our office and it'll give you
some information about that, but you have to be patient for not just a genetic consult
of ours.
Okay, so the genetic test also gives you things like peanut allergy.
Does this mean the person has two ones here that they should be off peanuts?
Well, in my perspective, probably everybody should be off peanuts, pick a different type
of nut to eat, peanuts have a lot of mycotoxins, especially if you have Lyme disease or bold
issues, you should not be eating peanuts anyhow.
So also gives you information about caffeine consumption, dude.
Are you a good caffeine metabolizer?
Does it give you the right to eat, to drink five pots of coffee, but if you actually have
a defect here, you metabolize caffeine better.
That's great, but still doesn't mean it's good for you, doesn't mean it's good for your
Dorito glands, doesn't mean it's good for the rest of your body, but you do at least metabolize
it better.
People that have blagues down here at this one on the bottom here, this caffeine metabolization,
really shouldn't be drinking coffee at all.
So if you have a two, you can drink some coffee, that's what I tell my patients.
You can drink some coffee, but within a reason, it also depends on if the person has a
dreidel fatigue or not, because then I won't let them drink coffee either.
The FUT2 genes, this is probably arguably one of the most important genes right here of
your whole genetic profile.
Why?
Because all ill health starts in the gut.
You can argue that really because inflammation starts in the gut, so many diseases begin in
the gut.
So the FUT2 genes, what these do is these make the enzymes in order to help heal the epithelial
cells of the gut so that you can make butyrate and you can feed the intestinal cells so that you
can hold a microbiota.
So your microbiota is your flora of your gut.
The symbiotic organisms that are living in your gut that are helping you absorb nutrients,
helping you stimulate an immune function, keeping you safe from pathogens, and keeping inflammation
down in your body.
There are your immune regulatory function.
If you don't have that healthy microbiota, your T-regulator cells, that's a part of your
immune system that keeps your immune system balanced.
That is out of balance and you're going to develop autoimmune diseases, you're going
to develop diseases.
So the FUT2 genes are so important.
This person has a really good picture here because the six most important FUT2 genes, when
we look at these genes, they can see FUT2 on the top and there's a bunch of genes underneath.
So I refer to those as the family of genes.
These are the family of FUT2 genes.
So there's a bunch of different FUT2 genes.
There's going to be some that are more weighted, meaning that the studies have shown, at least
up to this point, that they are the most important of all the FUT2 genes.
In this case, it's the top three in the bottom three.
This person doesn't have any defects in the top three, doesn't have any defects in the bottom
three.
Woo-hoo!
This is the time for celebration.
They should go dense and irish jig in the street because this person, if they have to take
antibiotics for a really bad infection, let's say, they're going to damage their microbiota,
but this person, because they have no FUT2 gene defects in the most important ones, they're
going to, that microbiota is going to heal quite quickly.
So here's a picture, right here, a genetic picture of a person who, yeah, I had acute
Lyme disease, I had to take 30 days at Doxocycline, like God was really bothering me, affected
by bowel wound, but I took probiotics in a couple of weeks, I was back to normal.
Versus another person, which might be you, is you're looking at your genetic profile,
you have, you know, three ones in the top three, and three ones in the bottom two, the bottom
three, or you have two's, some two's in there, and you're like, whoa, well, maybe that's
why it's taking me so long to recover from X, Y, or Z.
I took antibiotics for something, when I was a kid, when I was on antibiotics for ear infections
all the time, baby, that was a prerequisite for my current state of disease, and I never
really got back healthy again, and you're really thinking correctly there, FUT2 gene defects
cause all sorts of problems.
Now, there's another gene defect that I didn't get in the slide presentation that is in
your, that's the BCMI gene, that's in your report right now, because it's just been updated,
that has to do with vitamin A conversion.
So why do we have that under the gut function genes?
Vitamin A is so crucial to heal your epithelial cells.
So your gut cavity is made up of epithelial cells.
Epithelial cells come from a histological cell line, your epithelial cell line, that make
up that coach your intestinal tract, that actually make up all the cells that coach your, all
your inner cavities, so your throat, and your both is all epithelial cells, actually your
skin is epithelial cells, actually the cells that line your blood vessels are specialized
epithelial cells that we call endothelial cells, they come from that epithelial cell line,
they require vitamin A in order to heal.
If you have a lot of those defects, and you can look at your report, I don't have a slide
on it.
A lot of those defects, we put them in the gut health category because that's so important
to help your gut heal.
So that suggests an increased need for vitamin A for you, and I'll tell you, we as Americans
were deficient in a lot of these nutrients because they're not in our food, or we're eating
prepared foods, or we're eating foods that have synthetic supplementation that are enriching
the foods, and because we're deficient in those, we're not going to heal as well.
So you can start to get a picture of your health when you look at your genes, I have a lot
of those defects, I have a lot of FUT2 gene defects, I haven't really investigated my gut issues
and food issues because I don't really have tummy problems, I have normal digestion, but
if you have any systemic disease, whether it's brain issues, ADD, ADHD, depression, sadness,
anxiety, unclear thinking, to a lot of chronic Lyber cancer, you have to look at the food
piece, you have to look at the digestion piece, your microbiota, I cannot hold on this enough,
your microbiota is so important.
Another genes that we put in the same digestive category has to do with histamine, though these
genes that ABP1 genes have to do with histamine breakdown, how does histamine get broken down
in the gut? I have a whole page on my website with a ton of data on histamine, make sure you
look at that, especially if you have these gene defects that we're going to talk about in
the next couple of slides here, histamine is a immune function chemical, it's needed in
your body, remember, all the chemicals in your body, there's really no bad guys and good
guys, anything could be a bad guy if it's out of balance, if things are good guys, if
they're in balance, histamine is a good guy if it's in balance, if we have the ability
to break down histamines from our food, that's this ABP1 gene, so this particular person
has a 2 here, so they have some issues with the ability to break down histamine, so they
might be better to go, at least address the amount of histamine foods they're eating, and
our website we have a list of histamine foods, so you can look at that, now understand, most
foods have some histamine in it, the older the food is, the more aged the food is, the more
histamines it's going to have, eggs, for instance, have chicken eggs, have histamine in it, if
you get eggs from your own chicken coop and eat them today, they're going to have far
less histamine in it, that if you bought them at the grocery store, they sat your refrigerator
for two weeks and then you ate them, it's going to have way more histamines in it, meat
has some histamines in it, aged meat has a lot of histamines in it, nuts have histamines
in it, fermented foods have a lot of histamines in it, so people that have a lot of ABP1 genes,
maybe worse than this, even this person, if they have a serious disease, like cancer, I'll
say we got to cut back on your histamines, even have it a two there, one two there
out of those four genes, would still ignite me to say, you have to look at that histamine list,
you're never going to zero your histamines, so that's not even the point, so what the point
is, wow, I eat fermented foods all the time, I thought they were good for you, they are
good for you, they have a lot of probiotics in them, but they do have a lot of histamines,
please it's all about balance, it's all about balance, nothing in life is just cut dry
if I do this so I'm going to solve my problems, that's not life, you're living in Lala land,
it's all about balance, so okay, I have some histamine gene defects, so this person doesn't
really have a lot, you're going to see on the next slide, but if I did have a lot, then
you really have to think about reducing your histamine load.
The ABP1 gene is the gene that makes the enzymes that actually make DAO enzyme that breaks
down histamine in your food, so you're not just flooding your body with histamine.
This next gene, this HNMT gene, breaks down histamine in the tissues, so that you get rid
of it, your immune system actually makes histamine, has a purpose in an immune response, but when
you don't break it down very well, then you have excess histamine and you have symptoms
of excess histamine, stuffy nose, tight chest, heart palpitations, skin irritations, skin
rashes, watery eyes, blah blah blah, there's a ton of histamine issues on our website, I
list a whole bunch of other things out, but when you do have histamine issues, you've got
to go, should I take it into histamine?
No, those are not good for you at all, and they have other side effects that I list on this
page on our website, but I need to look at my genetics.
Do I have the ability to break down histamine really well?
And maybe that's an issue.
Now this particular person only has three twos at all these genes, I'd say they really
probably don't need to watch their histamine, unless they're having a lot of high histamine
symptoms, but I've seen patients with ones, almost every one of these, and ones in twos
and almost every one of these, that person absolutely positively needs to watch their histamine,
because histamine is increased inflammation, increased inflammation equals all sorts of
symptoms, tons of brain issues, ADD, ADHD, unclear thinking, cloudiness, anxiety, etc.
As histamine breaks down, it breaks down to the products that we don't really want to deal
with.
So hist, HNMT, is how we break down histamine in the tissues.
If you have a lot of gene defects here, you can go to our website and download the histamine
list, food list, and cut those down into size big time.
Histodine breaks down through the path, actually histodine breaks down and makes glutamate.
Glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter that most people have issues with and will be
talking about on another presentation, causes anxiety, OCD kit, let things go, get fall asleep
at night, doesn't sleep well, etc., etc.
So it's broken down through the ABP1 gene, it's broken down through the HNMT gene, very,
very important.
If you have defects in there, you're going to have access histamine, quite simple.
So this is the food list, it's a whole 30 food list of different histamines, the things
that are lighter gray, like up on the top says seafood and shellfish, shellfish have a lot
of histamine.
So if you read the instructions here, read the directions on the list that you could download,
don't try to just read it off the slide, but download this list and put it in your purse
so you go to the store, see eggs are lighter gray, they have a lot of histamine in it.
So you're best off getting the organic pasteurized right from the chicken, so pasteurized, I mean
not pasteurized.
Right from the chicken, store bought, the older it is, the more histamine it's going to have
over there, you could read this list.
And again, you have to understand, you're never going to eliminate histamines and your diet,
and that's not even the purpose, so don't go crazy about this.
But you just make some different choices, huh, I'm going to decrease my histamine load and
see if that makes a difference.
Now again, if you're interested in becoming a full patient of ours, then you've got to follow
the first steps tab on our website and do a complete case review and decide to become
a full patient of ours.
That's not what this is for, so please understand what you did a genetic review with us, it's
a different picture, you're a full patient of ours, you agreed to those 23andMe agreements.
You're receiving this video series, you're getting your genetic SNP report, so if you haven't
gotten us your 23andMe username and password, make sure you get that.
To us, and if you haven't got your results back, you will get this next piece, that genetic
SNP report, when we get your results back, and then your supplement report, so you'll get
that too.
And again, those are going to be solely completely 100% based upon the questionnaire that you
said this and your genetics.
I can't base it upon that you have cancer or that you have live or that you have anything
else, you have to go to your doctor for that.
I'm solely doing a supplement report based upon your genetics, so you have to understand
that, and I can't take it to consideration anything else, because I haven't done an examination
on you, so let's just be realistic here, and then understand, due to our busy schedule
here, you can't call the office and ask questions, like, oh he said the other supplement report
to take this histamine scavenger, and I took it and I got a tummy ache, should I keep
taking it?
Well that's, you're going to have to talk to your local doctor about that.
I could only make recommendations based upon your genetic report, and even if I put take
three a day, and you could only handle one a day, well, then don't take one a day.
So you have to use your common sense, you got to know that you are a different person than
your genetics, too, and you have to doctor yourself here, because I'm not your full doctor.
So contact your local doctor, if you don't have a local doctor, you don't find one.
If you want to use us, go back to that other slide and go back to the first steps, but you
have to follow the rules.
So please do that, don't call our office, don't email us with questions with that, unless
you want to go ahead and become a full patient, we just, we have to follow the rules, okay?
So please understand that.
This is what you're going to get, this is a supplement report, and this will help you, again,
follow it to the best you can, if you can't do this, or you can't afford those, then you
know, pick a couple that, you know, as you're going through this presentation, you should,
you should come up with your own understanding a little bit, this is a really rocket science.
If, if you really feel histamine is the worst thing for you right now, based upon your genes
and maybe you don't want to do any supplements and you want to just cut out histamine, I'm
not telling you what to do, I'm just making my best recommendation based upon your genes.
So we're limited to that, so you're going to have to doctor yourself and use, use your
doctor locally as well, so I care about you, I only want the best for you, I'm not trying
to sell stuff to you, so please don't get me wrong, but I have to give you my best recommendation,
so I just, I hope you understand that.
So this was the digestive part of this, I have presentations for, I know, seven or eight
more of these, so watch those, and you know, if, if you have a lot of gene defects in a certain
section, maybe you just want to jump to that, that's fine too, so whatever you want to
do.
And again, the other thing is that I wrote in, in the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the
written part of this, I'm not trying to make you all geneticist, so you don't just think
you have to understand all this, but the, the piece that really appeals to you and if you're
hungry for knowledge, I'm trying to give people that, so, um, utilize it to the best that
you can and to the depth that you want.
So I appreciate you listening and thank you very much.